now as is often been the case i want to
try and make sure this is as valuable to
you as possible um and i often think to
myself well should i just give you the
solution like my solution and just read
through it and for me when i read
someone else's solution
the most valuable part of that solution
especially with proof questions like
this is not present in the written
solution um the most valuable part of it
is why would such a person think to do
or to take such a line of reasoning why
would they use that kind of deductive
logic what made them think oh i should
connect this side and this angle and all
that kind of thing so what i want to try
and do is talk you through two methods
for part one we'll go through part two
fairly briefly i think it's quite
routine i think that's what you'll find
it's just a bit of careful algebra and
substitution but i really want you to
understand the concepts underneath this
because that's what you can apply to
questions that will look nothing like
this but are still nonetheless within 3d
vectors okay so i think i've got a spot
here um which i've called method one and
what i want to do is sort of laser focus
you in on what's relevant in this
question and what's missing okay so it
says what's the question asking show
that ac is equal to and then you've got
this relationship over here on the right
hand side with m
and n which are both sort of um they're
they're these uh
proportional relationships between um
the length ac and the length bc right
which we'll come back to in a second so
before we get to any of that sort of
nuts and bolts what i want to identify
is there's vectors in this question you
can see them there in the diagram and
there's vectors in the equation which
will help us work out what's a like if
we sort of put them over the top of each
other and work out the overlap that will
sort of chart a path through the
question for us so watch as i kind of
try to reason my way through this and
hopefully this will be helpful to you
ac this is kind of the focus of this
particular question this particular
proof so let's start by putting ac on
the diagram right and i've coded it
purple so there is ac right there
between a and c no problems okay
what other vectors do we have in play
well we've also got b
lower case b so if i highlight there
where is lowercase b in terms of this
kind of start point endpoints like you
know arrow and um and tail kind of way
of describing a vector that's going to
be ob right from o to b the origin
that's what it is by definition and you
can see it labeled there but what i'm
going to do is i'm going to superimpose
that on the diagram just so that i can
start to piece together this jigsaw
puzzle of how all of the different
vectors are going to relate to each
other
so there's ob
and then the third vector that gets
explicitly called out is a which you
know using the same logic is oa here so
you can see there's a i've actually
drawn it backwards because that's just
the way my hand went but there you go
there's our way right
now when you have a look at this we want
a relationship between ac
ob and oa and if you have a look at
what's sort of
formed here there's kind of a very
obvious missing piece that doesn't
appear in the equation but it does
appear in the diagram which i think
we're going to have to reckon with right
and you can see there it's this c b
vector not to be confused with b c
because obviously direction matters so c
b over here is kind of a missing piece
it sort of completes this triangle right
and what it shows us is if we take this
green vector in this purple vector which
we want and if we add on this missing cb
vector then what you'll get is this blue
vector so we will have this relationship
between green purple and blue which is
exactly what i need down here
i'm just going to have to somehow get
rid of the fact that there's cb in there
right there's no cb appearing here so
i'm going to have to use the
relationships in the question to
eliminate c
b well how will i do that
go back to the question i sort of
scrolled off there on screen but i'll
write it for you again we have this
relationship given to us too daisy that
cb on a c is equal to
m over m right so that tells you you've
got this relationship here this is kind
of m times longer than some unit if this
is n times longer than some unit that's
what the cb to ac relationship is so you
can see i can reason from this and say
well therefore um this is just talking
about the lengths but i can convert this
into a vector statement by saying well i
can talk about this in terms of uh cb
being
a proportion of that ac right m over n
i've just multiplied both sides by ac
and then because c b and ac are parallel
right therefore their direction is the
same the only difference between them is
this magnitude which i have the constant
coefficient therefore so therefore i can
reason that uh i'll just use this color
that's fine the vectors i actually can
make the same statement about them right
actually you know what i shouldn't do
that i should write it separately i can
say since
c oopsy daisy
cb is parallel to ac so the direction is
preserved therefore oopsie daisy sorry
guys making this move everywhere
therefore this statement here covers the
magnitude part of it right so i've got
direction handled and just the
magnitudes are different so there
there's where i get this statement from
cb i can substitute it the vector for m
on n times why am i writing that
backwards a
c
okay so this is an important part i mean
this is a show that question right so
it's important you don't just skip over
that's why i sort of caught myself
before this and then make the vector
statement right it's only true because
you've got this relationship of
magnitude and you've got this
relationship of direction okay
all right once you've got that you're
sort of ready to go i can just fit the
pieces of the puzzle together and this
will give us our two marks this is kind
of i'd say one of the marks is the
reasoning here um in fact not just i
would say the hse marketing guidelines
which i encourage you to download by the
way they're very very helpful um if
you're ever unsure like when you're
trying to read and interpret like what
does this actually mean just let mrs
lisa i know be happy to help you out
but in this case
i know that getting this relationship
here and showing the reason why that's a
whole fifty percent of this right well
let's do the other fifty percent
uh ac is on the left hand side so let's
start with saying i can go from o a
to a
c to c
b so that is going along from the origin
up to a over to c and then to b
that is the same if you just have a look
at my a's being strung together and my
c's being strung together that's just
the same as going from o to b can you
see that you can see how i've added it
all up together just by concatenating
all those vectors one after the other
and now i just have a substitution to
make in order to get from this to some
of our lower case with our tilde vector
notation right so i'll substitute this
for a
i'll leave ac i don't need to change
that because that's going to be part of
what's in my final line
i'm going to substitute this cb that i
said before because there is no cb in
the final
line that we're trying to prove it's m
on n
times a c so you can see there's going
to be some collecting of like terms by
factorization there
and then on the right hand side i've got
b right
so this is kind of most of the heavy
lifting has been done at this point i
just need to carefully rearrange and
look after my algebra so it looks like
i've got ac
left on this side and i can take out
that factor leaving me with this inside
the brackets and then as sort of
predicted if you have a look at where
you're headed you've got this b minus a
so that's why i sub subtract a from both
sides to get it over there on the right
hand side
i'm almost there right i'm just going to
put this into combine into one fraction
to make the division a bit easier and
you can't skip this right it's a show
that question so don't don't go past
this this crucial part of the logic um
this is going to be
n over n that's the one right so n over
n plus m over n will give you this
uh nothing has changed over here on the
right hand side
and then i just need to divide through
so i will do ac or you could cross
multiply if you prefer to think about it
that way to n
on m plus n and then here's the b
minus a that we were required to prove
so that's it
as required okay